[موسيقى]
في عام
تعرف العالم على الفيروس القاتل ماربرج
بعد اكتشافه لدى عمال في مدينه المانيه
لذا حمل الوباء الجديد اسمها بعد تعرضهم
لملامسه مباشره مع القرود الخضراء
الافريقيه هناك اليوم يعود القلق العالمي
مج
[موسيقى]
ديدا تتجاوز 90% غينيا الاستوائيه عزلت
بشكل احترازي لنحو 200 من المواطنين فيها
فيما اعلنت اسبانيا عن تسجيل اول حاله
اشتباه للفيروس بعد زياره لغينيا
الاستوائيه كذلك فقد عزلت اسبانيا اعضاء
الرحله الاربعه والثلاثين في سبيل اجراء
المزيد من الفحوصات لهم في وقت تسعى
الكثير من الهيئات الصحيه عالميا بايجاد
لقاح للفيروس المميت الى لميس
يعرف فايروس مارفل باسم حمى ماربرج
النزفيه وهي حمى شديده العدوى تنتمي الى
عائله مرض فيروس ايبولا الفيروس يتشابه مع
ايبولا من الناحيه الاكلينيكيه ويؤدي الى
احداث تفشيات وبائيه مع معدلات وفيات
عاليه وتنتج عدوى برج البشريه عند التعرض
المطول للمناجم او الكهوف التي تسكنها
مستعمرات خفافيش الفاكهه ويؤكد الاطباء
المتخصصون ان الانسان يبقى معديا ما دام
الفيروس موجودا في دمه ويستهدف الفيروس
الخلايا المناعيه في جسم الانسان ويتسبب
بعدم تنشيط الجسم بشكل صحيح لاستجابه
خلايا الدم البيضاء للفيروس
ولهذا الفيروس اعراض عديده تشبه
الانفلونزا لحد كبير ومنها الحمى والصداع
والقشعريره والام الجسم وايضا اليرقان او
اصفرار لون الجلد والعينين واحيانا الطفح
الجنسي
[موسيقى]
على كل المزيد ينضم لنا استشار الامراض
الباطنيه والماضيه دكتور نزار بهابرينا
دائما دكتور نزار يسعد يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
معنا صباح العربيه
اسعد الله صباحكم جميعا وجميع المشاهدين
طيب دكتور نسمع منك اكثر تفاصيل عن هذا
الفيروس القديم الجديد فيروس ماربور وكيف
يختلف عن الانفلونزا عنده نفس الاعراض
صداع حمى والم في الجسم
[موسيقى]
انا ابغى اكد على انه في شيء جدا مهم مننا
احنا دائما نقيم به الفيروسات دائما نقيم
فيه الفيروسات طريقه الانتقال
سرعه الانتقال
وجود دواء او لا يوجد دواء او لقاح اوكي
يصير اول حاجه نبغى نعرف انه هذا الفيروس
صحيح قديم من 1900
عده مرات انتشر فيها من ضمنها اخرها الى
ينتشر بين الاشخاص زي اي بولو هو في شريحه
من من الفيروسات تنتقل عن طريق خفاش او زي
الناموس يسموها الحمى النزيفيه يعني ايش
النزيفيه يعني الفيروس عنده القدره اذا
يتكاثر يخلي الجسم ينزف
يقلل الصفائح الدمويه يخلي الجسم ينزف
اقلهم ضررا يعني اللي يسوي حاجه زي كذا هو
اللي منتشر في بعض الدول العربيه وبما
فيهم جده
يعتبر حمى نزيفيه يعني يسبب نزيف لكن من
الاشهر عالميا اللي معروف مره الايبولا
هذا مره قريب بس دكتور نزار انت عم تشرح
لنا كيف بس كيف يعني مثلا بكون في فيروس
عمره 70 سنه برجع كانه بيخلق من جديد
وبتكاسر مره اخرى ويظهر فينا وبصير بشكل
مميت كمان مره واحده
احسنتي احسنت لانه هو حقيقه الفيروس
فيروسات موسميه زي الانفلونزا تتكاثر
وتنتقل من شخص الى شخص دائما ايش اللي
احنا نركز فيه الانتقال عن طريق النسم عن
طريق النسم فبالتالي هذا ليس من هذه من
هذه الفئه ليس من هذه الفئه هو من الفعل
لتنتقل عن طريق الدم او
السوائل يعني لا سمح الله مختار احتكاك
طبيعي بالشخص المصاب يعني ما ينفع اي
انتقال فبالتالي ما هو الشيء اللي يمدينا
مثلا واحد راكب باص ويعدي كل اللي في
الباص ما في حاجه زي كذا هذا لازم يكون في
احتكاك نظرا لانك انت ما انت عارفه كمان
ينتقل للناس اللي مثلا في القطاع الصحي
لانهم هم ما كانوا عارفين بيتعاملوا مع
السوائل الخارجه من انفه ولا من حلقه
يتطاير شيء من هم بيشفوا طوله فهذه
الاشياء هي اللي تنتقل لشخص اخر يدخل
الفيروس يتكاثر ممكن يؤدي الى ارتفاع في
السخونه بعدين هبوط في قراءه الدم البيضاء
الحمراء وممكن يؤدي الى النزيف فنبغى نطمن
اول حاجه نظرا من يوم ما تلاقي الموضوع ما
ينتقل بالنفس والاعداد ما هي متكاثره يقل
الاستثمار سواء كان في تطعيم او في دواء
فبالتالي علشان كذا هو ما ينتقل بالنفس
ونكد ننتقل بالافرازات
يتكرر بين فتره والاخرى نظرا لاحتكاك
الانسان مثلا زي ما انت قدمنا في التقرير
الرائع جدا هو في علاقه شديده
عده حيوانات او طيور موجوده في الكهوف
فبالتالي هو ينتقل في هذه الدول هذه الدول
واحد منها يسافر الى منطقه اخرى زي
اسبانيا يقوم يقيمون ويقولوا اه والله هذا
جاني منطقه يتكاثر فيها فعشان كذا هو
يتكاثر بين فتره والاخرى اذا رجع الانسان
احتك بنفس هذه الحيوانات او الطيور شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه التوضيحات استشاري امراض
الباطنيه والمعديه دكتور نزار هبري شكرا
جزيلا دكتور